I'm gonna give my pride and joy Jenkins
the cat for one weekend only to carry
who in return which doesn't feel like a
very fair trade is going to give me some
kind of a dog and we're going to see
what it's like when a dog person takes a
cat for a weekend and a cat person takes
a dog for a weekend it's time to pack
for Goldie is overnight stay with Uncle
Jack this is cat food that he likes and
Jenkins his favorite cat toy this is her
favorite port right here of favor to
people I mean my wife Sarah okay so I'm
a little nervous about this weekend
because I don't like to give up Jenkins
to someone else so jack is my boss and
I'm taking his most beloved prized child
gift of a cat for a weekend so there's a
lot of pressure so I have to win over
Deakins or else something
okay Jenkins is here didn't get to see
it Peter is mom now
hey yeah all cats are great but Jenkins
among cats is basically the pinnacle of
what a cat can be and I've also not
spent a lot of time around dogs so I
don't really know how to be around dogs
I grew up with cats if she's outside I
would keep her on a leash at all times
she's the Comus when she's had exercise
okay she gonna like the baby I think she
probably will just sniff Cyril
we also have a baby I'm excited because
I think that I should learn how to love
cats more than I do right now okay so we
just went on our first walk which I'm
calling a success I kind of up the
degree of difficulty by bringing a baby
with me and the dog kept wanting to go
on one side and then the other of me
while we were walking and basically
we'll wrap up me and a baby in her leash
which made things a little difficult and
made me look a little bit of a fool but
other than that it went really well
cats how do you play with them not sure
I've been doing all the things that jack
has told me to do by slowly putting out
my arm and having jinkins smell my hand
and I'm men making little noises that
chickens not hopefully it's ticking so
like me yes you wanna come to the bar
all day everybody's gone
Jenkins has been playing this evening
and loves to be petted and slowly
approached oh look at that cat can't do
this whoo I said well that's why we
watch a movie that seems pretty good
okay so I figured out that actually this
is how we watch a movie she sits on the
couch with us that's nice
Jenkins
[Music]
just wants to be closed for bedtime
there's nothing wrong with a little bit
of snuggling we're best friends now okay
it's 3:30 let the UH with the nice dog
sleep in the bed which is a nice that
the last 15 minutes yourself I learned
to play which was less nice because it's
3:30 a.m. it's 3:30 in the morning and
not 3:30 in the afternoon
update the cat I've been meowing all
night I'm not getting any sleep at all
[Music]
it's probably bad for dogs
all right so its morning time at 7:00
a.m. we got through the night eventually
Goldie's tillow down now there's a lot a
lot of action in the morning would the
dog eat a little bit more than I than
I'm used to
it's the next morning sitting outside
drinking some much-needed coffee because
I was up all night
see cat it woke me up at least every two
hours
jinkins not on my favorites list right
now because I really like my sleep so
here's something that's fun with a dog
is needed out of the bathroom
[Music]
you got a friend just waiting for you
like she's been sitting outside the
whole time
Jenkins is now under my bed just chillin
not making a peep where he's been a
couple of hours now so he definitely has
his days in his nights confused fire
hydrant goldie that is so basic come on
you can do better than that let's find
something interesting alright so here we
are reunited at yard bar this is
paradise for dogs los Baldy and frankly
I wouldn't be able to tell which one she
is anymore she's having a ton of our
lines so Wow what it what it what are
you gonna do as an equivalent treat for
Jenkins quid pro quo so in the
instructions there is a little bit about
having the cat sit in my lap in read a
book and I'm looking forward to that
moment I really hope it happens okay
Jenkins was very active last night like
like I had a newborn child and I'm
really rethinking having children
someday okay
have you told him that he lights up your
life and that you love him I'm not there
yet okay alright I wanna pressure you
would since it okay and so I've been
holding that okay alright well stay
tuned for that
tomorrow we are swapping back the pets
and I'm feeling relieved about that
because I think that the pets are gonna
be back with their
you know one love the best
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're going home we're taking
Baldy hump she seems very excited on the
sweetheart so the time has come for me
to give Jenkins back to Jack I am
feeling ready but also sad because my
new friends leaving me Jenkins as soon
as he got out of the carrier acted as if
nothing had happened
went to go try and eat the dog's food
and then he went to go and smell all the
places the dog had been and then he was
like right back to normal I wish Jenkins
was here I want to say up front that
Goldie is my friend and she's a good
girl but I was ready to bring her back
to her rightful home at the end of the
weekend
I do miss Jenkins sweet face and his
cuddly soft cute little body and his
snuggles I was ready to give Jenkins
back I have no plans to be purchasing a
cat for myself or adopting it kept for
myself under no circumstances ever no
matter what happens will I ever get a
dog I would get ten cats I would get ten
cats before I got a dog but that said
Goldie and I had had a pretty nice time
and she was really sweet with my family
I'd also like Cyril my son to visit
called E again because he really really
loved her I think Jenkins is a special
cat I think that I will have an open
heart towards all cats now and not just
avoid them in the future I will always
extend a hand and try to be friends with
a cat if I see it
[Music]
[Music]